soucieux d'en parler ce soir vous savez
qu'on parle de tout et c'est vrai qu'à
une multitude d'artistes a été sorti par
bfm business
et derrière un nul mandat article qui
disait que ont plombé voilà donc notre
assureur des productions à lever nos
productions les comptes de ces 8
on va revenir sur les faits qui les a
pas les révéler mais juste moi je
voudrais savoir parce qu'on dit que dans
l'arctique que les les dépenses de la
chaîne ont augmenté de 46% c'est à dire
vraiment presque le double comment
est-ce que vous l'expliquer et ben haim
j'adore est à dire qu on dirait qu'on en
conférence de presse
benaïssa benhaim de capital notamment le
dire alors non mais franchement il ya eu
beaucoup de nouveautés et william à midi
qui est arrivé à dakar il ya eu tir
ardisson qui a eu une à cannes émission
le service et le dimanche
voilà donc forcément ça renforce la
chaîne mais ça coûte aussi des sous à
gouesnou il faut savoir un truc c'est
qu'on a toujours le même volume depuis
cinq ans donc c'est exactement la même
chose je vous dis la vérité
jamais on a fait une aussi belle année
puisque c'est que de la télé marche très
bien et est rentable et pmp vous l'avez
vu ça fait rien ça fait gagner 60
millions d'euros à la scène lorsque 18
millions par an voilà est ici c'est le
moine marche très bien et va continuer
strike a très bien marché et ça continue
voilà donc à car je n'ai pas compris en
fait voilà mais il paraît même que les
recettes de ces villes les recettes de
ces vite c'est 50% grâce à tpm paie donc
je vois pas quel goût et la polémique
mais oui qu'on paye 50 100 200 300 et il
peu importe si ça rapporte plus le
problème alors je n'avais après voilà
après volaille et disco on plombe les
comptes je vous expliquais un petit peu
tous les comptes de ces vite mais
d'abord posé mois ils disent que le
chiffre d'affaires de ces 8 a baissé de
10%
oui entre autres à cause des trois
semaines de suppression de pub du à la
caméra cachée sur mathieu et en vendre à
la caméra cachée sur la grèce et le
monde font l'incident de capucine oui
alors c'est l'article alors que s'il
avait ou bien je vais vous dire
l'histoire les eaux dans l'histoire
puisqu'il ya eu il ya eu la fermeture il
ya eu d'affaires capucine et il ya eu
d'affaires radio bâle a fait radio baba
ça ça nous accueillons des trois
millions d'années nous ça c'est acté
même par par le conseil d'état oui parce
qu'on a le droit d'aller voir un recours
au conseil d'état et les deux affaires
qui sont capucines à naves et les
matthieu delormeau qui nous ont coûté
trois semaines de suppression pub un
manque à gagner d'environ 10 millions à
10 à 15 millions d'euros
sachez que ça a été retoqué par le
conseil d'état et qu'a priori
voilà donc
ça serait rétro et on va voir on aura
les réponses dans deux à trois semaines
sachez que ça a été retoqué par le
conseil d'état que la décision a été
retoqué la décision du csa êtres
l'archipel csa c'est normal ils ont reçu
plein de plainte c'est normal qu'ils
voient là justin mais en tout cas voilà
pour l'instant en tout cas ça a été
retoqué par le conseil d'état qui est le
recours au csa vacances certes ok comme
ça ça veut dire que donc finalement il
fallait pas en retirer ces trois
semaines mais si dans ce coup il ya eu
on a retiré trois semaines pour rien ou
vous avez récupéré l'argent sur tout
mais on va doit on va devoir se
retourner comme césar entreprises
arriverait si long
forcément après on va voir on va
peut-être trouvé un arrangement avec eux
ça se passe bien avec lui en ce moment
voilà mais en tout cas ça a été retoqué
par le c est par le conseil d'état oui
vous savez si je vous aime et suzanne
myre le contrat que vous avez signé mais
ce que dit quand même l'article etc est
pas faux c'est qu'une chaîne de la tnt
pour des gens comprennent bien en
général le coût de grille c'est à dire
l'entièreté de l'année ces 120 millions
non pour les gros chêne liège douce et
50 veut dire qu'une chaîne moyenne ces
60 70 millions d'euros même les matchs
de ces vite la drs jean 20 millions mais
c'est vrai que vous vous donnant 50
millions comme vous peut pas remplir
toute la grille et que vos émissions
bien ils sont menés quasiment de doubler
ou tripler le coût de grille pour
pouvoir derrière m 2 des émissions à
partir de là mais non là on leur fournit
on leur fournit on a fourni deux
émissions par jour voire plus énormément
de prague en fait dont ils disent ils
ont eu ce qu'ils voulaient dans leurs
cracks immeuble qui pour pour remplir
les grilles ne font pas de cadeaux voilà
il mais ce nom mais ils essaient de deux
chargés de construire l'autre et ratages
en est une en belgique oui pardon je
suis très très content je sait pas
calculer mais si je dis bien l'article
vous leur coûter 50 millions vous le
rapportez 60 millions de recettes juste
gmp ont déjà servi mignon déjà
exactement donc déjà dans les normes et
voilà donc déjà et ça et c'est sans
compter les prime times dont les
déclinaisons touche pas à mon poste
strike ici c'est le moine québec et
voilà qu'elle est rentable aussi il ya
voilà il ya c'est que de la télé qui a
cartonné donc voilà donc si je comprends
bien fait je vais vous dire cette partie
la table et il est plutôt bon c'est
plutôt bon signe quand on a ces articles
là c'est qu'on est largement leader mais
qui savent plus quoi trouver l'autre il
est extrêmement à charge article alors
on parle dans cet article de votre
contrat de 250 millions qui a été
renégocié
vous pouvez nous donner les précieuses
que 2020 que ça veut dire alors c'est
pas du tout jusqu'à 2023 je vous dirais
vérité moi je devais être sûr c'est vite
jusqu'à 2020 voilà jusqu'à 2020 et on a
une autre année voilà qui va être
on a signé avec m'associer traduction
h2o dans laquelle je ne serais peut-être
pas animateur mais juste producteurs de
contenus voilà pour ces vite
après peut-être que je resterai
d'animation ou peut-être que touche pas
à mon poste restera 100 moi je vous dis
toute la vérité c'est que de la télé
aussi peut-être restera sans bénéficier
si elle a des c s et décide de venir
s'installer avec moi la main
ces voix là mais en tout cas voilà on a
une année de plus on a on appris des
sous des années qui restait pour les
mettre en sur une année plus pour voilà
pour pouvoir faire des productions sans
moi peut-être à la tête de ces
démissions venu dans papier insiste
aussi l'arrêt de certaines émissions que
vous produisez part parce que jugés pas
assez rentables lesquels lesquels alors
je vais vous dire il nomme ici tôt cette
année joue lisse et très content merci
c'est une des plus belles années puisque
c'est que de la télé a cartonné strike
et cartonner ici c'est le moine a
cartonné touche pas à mon poste a
cartonné aussi cette année
donc voilà écouter en tout cas merci moi
j'avais vu une ballerine l'avenir h2o
est tous les prime ne touche pas à mon
poste ont pas fait moins 100 millions de
téléspectateurs donc voilà après voilà
ils ont voulu écrire ça coûte et voilà
on a tous les chiffres voilà donc voilà
un million de voix lasse il ya un mignon
baba normal activité un million de 1
million 2 millions 3 et 8 ans de tmp un
million cent voilà donc après c'est vrai
que dans les zones écrit cet article
moi je comprends les journalistes je
sais pas où ils ont eu des infos mais la
prochaine fois qu'ils m'appellent
directement riz et je leur donnerai
toutes les infos il y aura aucun souci
vous en à appelé du tout venant pas du
tout à ça du variable cola dupont un
travail si l'oeuf ou la poule qui a duré
deux ans quand même à l'antenne
derrière le poste tous les sujets ont
été faits et nora est parti donc on a
arrêté l'émission
voilà donc voilà donc pour toutes les
émissions voilages et je vous dis après
voilà il ya d'autres soumissions qui
arrive souligne avis de recherche qui va
arriver avec avec patrick sabatier ya
les ombres rouge c'est une fiction qui
va arriver à la rentrée aussi il ya la
scoumoune qui va arriver qu'un nouveau
jeu et il ya ici sur le moine qui va
resté baba noël et la grande roue sera
tout ça c'est un viendra également
d'autres questions du shérif est-ce que
vous pensez que la chaîne va réagir
alors je crois pas je crois pas c'est
maintenant je crois que la chaîne ne
réagira pas voilà je vous le dis vous en
appelez cite à cet article pas du tout
mais la chaîne ne m'appelle que dit
alors j'ai un texto du président de la
chaîne alors à travailler ou les rangs
direct monnaie comme ça ils arrivent
voilà bah non c'est francs capitaux qui
me dit merci frérot pour la voix de
merde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ces huit voilà ça se passe super bien
avec ses 8 vraiment on est hyper content
on a fait une très belle saison et c'est
vrai que mathieu a juste te dire un truc
qui est vrai c'est que aujourd'hui voilà
il y en a en a on a un contrat qui est
assez important donc on essaie de faire
voilà travailler le maximum de monde
on essaie de mettre le plus de choses à
l'antenne que soient des fictions des
émissions de divertissement des jeux on
va continuer à le faire mais c'est vrai
que voilà aujourd'hui pour une chaîne de
la tnt le contrat et est important donc
il faut fournir beaucoup beaucoup de
programmes
voilà c'est comme je vous dis la vérité
c'est comme yann barthès sur tmc qu'un
très gros contrats qui doivent fournir
faire des pauses beaucoup de choses
voilà il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
touche pas à mon poste je vous dis ça
coûte 80 mille euros par jour en
quotidien coûte 110 euros
gemalodo voilà donc oui donc c'est tout
pas prêt on plombe pas les comptes mais
si les journalistes pensent qu on plombe
les comptes et bas qui viennent nous
donner un petit peu de souffle merci
nationale allait cesser c'est fou voilà
devoir de genre d'articles ont été
repris en plus partout que je voudrais
inviter les journalistes mais avec
plaisir et bien s'ils veulent venir a dû
faire ça aujourd'hui est bon et ben vous
êtes quoi bien sûr livrera donc à venir
pour la spéciale sans voyage touche n'a
rien contre eux on a on n'a rien d'autre
juste la prochaine fois tu me pose la
question et puis comme ça se passera
bien voilà merci en tout cas si vous
avez d'autres questions ou jean luc tu
as peut-être vos questions te félicite
pour ta success story mais non mais vous
ramener autant de sourires dans les
foyers et la bonne humeur
ce que vous faites tous les jours
j'entends partout il ya 50 millions
d'euros par an il faut pas trop se
faisait il faut savoir que c'est pas
pour moi les 50 millions d'euros par an
bien sûr on a une société qui marche
très bien je vous dis la vérité on va
pas se mentir on va pas se plaindre et
on est très heureux et on essaye on y
sert encore d'aider le maximum de monde
grâce à ce qu'on fait à la télé mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas 50 millions
d'euros parce que j'entends et je lis
aussi des inepties qui disent que je
vois que je gagne 50 millions d'euros
par an chiffre d'affaires voilà je sais
beaucoup plus
non mais voilà on est déjà très très
content de ce qu'on fait et je vous dis
on est des privilégiés et on est juste
là pour se marrer et vous amuser tous
les soirs voilà je vous le dis merci
d'être là
[Applaudissements]